The influence of 3D computer graphics is all
around us. Sometimes its effects are
obvious, like when we see an action movie
or play a video game. Sometimes they are
not. Like when we take a sip of water or cut
a piece of paper.
Learning how to model and display objects
through computer graphics helps us to
understand, test and communicate ideas.
Take this apple for instance. When I first
began programming the state of the art
looked like this and took minutes to
compute. Over the past few decades, the
field has evolved at an incredible pace and
we’re now at the point where elaborate
effects can be presented through your web
browser in real time.
In this course, we’ll teach you the basics of
3D Computer Graphics, both practical and
theoretical. By the end you’ll not only
understand how to create and animate
objects, but will know the math that makes
this possible. You learn how to define
materials in lighting and also come to
understand the physics of how our eyes
perceive color. Only a basic understanding
of programming is needed. So come, join
us to learn some new ideas and get a fresh
look at the world around you.